there's some truth to some of the things  that Coco says because it's one of the  reasons that Pearl probably knew who she  was when she knew it is because you had  really great parents well-rounded  two-parent household but I I actually  don't agree entirely with you know the  red pill about oh go ahead and get out  there and get a husband as young as you  can and I think you have the most  leverage in your youth I can agree to  that I think you have a lot more options  at 20 to 24 but I can say that I don't  think most American women know  themselves until they're 24 and then I  mean even after that like there's a lot  of narcissistic clueless women running  around out here and they're going to be  a liability the problem is is that they  let the narcissism run its way into  their 30s and they're surprised like why  didn't my life work out it's because you  need a reality check and